quand vous oubliez de nettoyer la
gamelle du chien il vous la met comme
assiette
Christophe carrière bonsoir encore
alors Christophe on vous connaît
critique de cinéma à L'Express on vous
connaît chroniqueur de Cyril Hanouna
sur des villes une spéciale mais on
ignore tout de l'homme et vous venez de
loin Christophe vous venez d'une enfance
massacrée par un père sadique dont vous
apprendrez qu'il est bien des années
plus tard vous racontez votre histoire
dans un livre intitulé Un père et passe
publié chez Michel Lafont et vous nous
raconterez ici à 20h dans Salut les
Terriens
[Musique]
Christophe carrière bonsoir bonsoir
alors Christophe carrière vous êtes né
le 15 décembre 1964 à Clichy dans le 92
vos parents sont épicés c'est en tout
cas ce qui vous font croire à vous et à
votre entourage pendant de longues
années très tôt vous êtes placé en
nourrice et votre mère passe de temps en
temps pour faire un petit bisou mon coup
de vent oui oui très rapidement oui et
chez une nourrice pas pas très
recommandable pas très recommandable
parce que vous êtes mal nourris ce qui
fait qu'à l'âge de deux ans vous savez à
peine marcher et vous vous exprimez par
borborigme
de la joue j'étais plus gros je crois
que cette joue là
que vos parents vous confient un couple
d'amis hongrois qui habite au 10ème
étage d'une HLM de
Issy-les-Moulineaux et eux ils sont
sympas
lui il est très sympa mais d'ailleurs le
livre lui est dédié
son vrai nom c'est Juliette et voilà
c'est ma mère a adoptif quoi voilà ils
deviennent votre vrai papa et votre vrai
maman
les vrais passe pas souvent une fois par
mois une fois par mois ouais
malheureusement vous avez 9 ans quand
vos parents vous récupèrent
vous allez vivre à ce moment-là à
Boulogne-sur-Mer votre père il y a un
business de fruits et légumes et il vous
amène avec lui sur les marchés alors là
vous pensez encore pouvoir gagner son
amour et vous faites tout ce que vous
pouvez mais je ne pense qu'à ça même
ouais je me dis je les connais pas bien
mais j'ai vraiment envie d'être leur
enfant voilà que ce soit mes parents
quoi qui même comme leur enfant alors
quand vous déménagez à Ivry-sur-Seine là
l'ambiance devient carrément
insupportable il y a l'épisode terrible
du sandwich au gruyère vous n'aimez pas
le fromage vous voulez pas le manger
vous le jetez dans le vide ordure votre
père s'en aperçoit et vous allez avec
lui dans le local poubelle pour
retrouver le sandwich au gruyère et il
vous le fait manger c'est là où je me
suis dit ça va très très mal se passer
je suis mal barré quoi vraiment c'est
effectivement je mange de tout je suis
pas difficile et je n'aime pas le
fromage c'est pas grave voilà mais lui
il voulait absolument que je mange du
fromage
alors un soir et vous sert un bout de
camembert dans l'assiette vous allez
vomir aux toilettes vous n'aimez pas de
fromage mais quand vous revenez à table
il a mis un autre bout de camembert dans
l'assiette ouais ça allait jusqu'à 4
petit à petit la perversité de votre
père s'installe grave un jour il vous
dit être quelle couleur cette nappe vous
dites elle est blanche il dit non elle
est rouge exactement
voilà il adorait ça et là il me
renvoyait dans ma chambre où il avait
placardé au-dessus de mon lit le
règlement du chef l'article 1 c'est le
chef a raison article 2 le chef a
toujours raison et donc quand je
revenais à table il demandait devant
tout le monde à l'heure de quelle
couleur elle elle disait elle est rouge
et il me disait pourquoi parce que
l'article 2 le chef a toujours raison
alors par exemple si vous buvez pas un
verre d'eau avant le repas c'est un
front ouais il me faisait parler en fait
c'est à dire qu'il avait une méthode
c'était assez piège il me parlait
pendant voilà en mangeant ça et puis le
plat de résistance arrivait
là je commence à me parler je mange et
là à peine la première bouché dans la
bouche et vous êtes tous dans le front
ça j'avais pas vu le verre d'eau
alors un jour vous passez l'aspirateur
il vous fracasse le nez avec un cintre
allez là la marque vous comprenez pas
pourquoi il vous dit ça fait une pompe
que ta mère t'appelle voilà c'est ça
j'entendais pas je passais l'aspirateur
voilà mais comme voilà il lâchait pas
vraiment il me lâchait pas la grappe
ouais vous faites des journées de dingue
en plus à l'époque parce que le matin
avant l'école vous faites les étalages
de fruits et légumes et Dieu sait si
c'est compliqué ensuite à l'École le
soir après l'école faut tout réemballer
il faut faire les devoirs il faut
préparer le dîner enfin vous avez des
journées infernales en fait ma
récréation c'est d'aller à l'école ouais
j'adorerais l'école ça c'est la récré ah
ouais les autres comprenez pas moi
j'étais le ravi de la crèche moi
j'arrivais ouais youpi c'est l'école
quoi
après le dîner vous couchez pas tout de
suite parce qu'il vous garde sous la
main des fois qu'il a un truc à vous
demander quoi ouais c'est l'exercice du
pouvoir tout simplement c'est voilà
c'est ce qu'on appelle un pervers
narcissique et qui veut absolument
maîtriser manipuler jusqu'au bout quand
vous oubliez de nettoyer la gamelle du
chien il vous la met comme assiette
ouais en disant tu vois il t'aimerai pas
manger dans une assiette salle toi
pourquoi tu fais ça au chien voilà tout
était tout était sur le même modèle en
fait à chaque fois mettre en perspective
et toujours dire bah voilà tu comprends
si lui il fait ça alors toi pourquoi tu
ne ferais pas etc voilà c'est alors un
adolescent je voulais faire un bac
littéraire vous êtes assez doué lui vous
fassiez un bac scientifique un bac mais
vous vous êtes mauvais en science pour
pas très bon ouais alors la conseillère
d'orientation elle comprend rien là je
me rétave on me fait redoubler
évidemment en littéraire
et lui décrète comme je suis pas bon il
va me retirer de l'école donc à l'âge de
16 ans vous retrouvez à travailler à
travailler oui vous retrouvez vendeur de
fruits et légumes dans un supermarché du
12e arrondissement et c'est là que vous
apprenez quand même par une cliente que
votre père n'est pas votre père
exactement
en l'occurrence il avait un peu raison
mais
on peut pas lui donner de temps là vous
fuguer il vous retrouve
après il fait piquer votre chien sans
vous le dire là vous refugez parce que
c'est insupportable ouais ouais ça
c'était horrible ça c'est horrible il
emmenait du jour au lendemain quoi comme
ça alors là vous allez vous enfermer
dans un cinéma ouais prémonitoire de 14h
à minuit et puis vous décidez de
négocier votre émancipation
voilà je vais habiter tout seul tu me
dois 2 ans de salaire donne-moi l'argent
ça me permet de m'installer limite tu
rigoles en fait tu vis chez moi ça me
coûte de l'argent tes deux ans de
salaire ça c'est un truc ouais ça c'est
un truc assez incroyable c'est-à-dire
que tu m'as présenté l'addition voilà
tout ce que je devais depuis que j'étais
né donc ça veut dire que tu comptabilise
tout quoi alors c'est là qu'il vous
confirme qu'il est pas votre père
et que votre mère ne sait pas qui est le
père voilà ça devient compliqué pour
retrouver son vrai père là vous
installez qu'une jeune femme mère d'un
enfant dans une chambre de bonne de 9
mètres carrés c'est vrai et vous lui
faites un autre enfant oui vous êtes à
quatre dans 9 mètres carrés exactement
là vous décidez de monter un journal de
cinéma qui s'appelle ciné clap c'est une
bonne idée c'est l'amuse-gueule des
files d'attente c'est vrai quand les
gens attendent devant un cinéma c'est
très malin bravo et là votre père vient
vous voir un jour en disant nomme-moi
directeur de la rédaction parce que je
veux bénéficier des abattements fiscaux
des journalistes examens absolument
incroyable
c'est pas possible j'ai pas de filer un
titre dans mon journal il fait gaffe
j'ai déposé le titre alienpi alors en
réalité je vais vous dire le nom du
journal c'était c'était alors au début
c'était Ciné-Clap après c'était 7e art
il a déposé 7e art à l'INPI et j'ai
transformé le nom du journal en septième
artifice voilà que j'ai déposé alienpi
et j'ai continué sans le mettre
directeur de la publication vous avez
continué sauf que
vous êtes condamné à payer 115000 euros
donc 750 000 francs de redressement
fiscal à cause de lui à cause de lui il
m'avait mis en prête non sur une société
avec mon accord c'était c'était rien à
faire voilà il m'a dit ouais je te donne
1000 boules par mois puis juste tu vas
déposer un chèque tu retires en espèces
et voilà et moi franchement et tout le
monde dans mon entourage il y a des gens
qui le connaissaient qui m'ont dit ne le
fais pas il va t'en fumer et ils avaient
bien raison ouais il m'en fumé
ah bah il m'a paru ni j'avais pas cet
argent c'est une catastrophe moi j'avais
rien fait donc là vous trouvez votre
premier job vous êtes relation publique
pour private qui est le leader mondial
du film porno c'est vrai bah oui ensuite
ce sera le magazine Première L'Express
et évidemment Touche pas à mon poste
la vérité vous l'apprendrez par un pote
devenu commissaire de police qui bosse
au 36 quai des Orfèvres et il vous dira
ton père était proxénète et ta mère
était une prostituée ma mère était
effectivement une prostituée mon père
l'a mis sur le trottoir mais moi-même je
ne suis pas un enfant du trottoir et
j'ai appris quand j'ai écrit le livre
parce que j'ai posé des vraies questions
à ma mère c'est pas facile de demander
ça à sa mère et pour la mère c'est pas
facile pour elle de le dire elle m'a
donc avoué qu'effectivement elle avait
elle est partie de chez elle quand elle
était mineure au début des années 60
donc c'était pas simple elle est elle
avait deux amants qu'elle aimait
vraiment elle est tombée enceinte elle
ne sait pas du tel des deux elle a
largué les deux elle a gardé l'enfant
elle m'a mis en Norris et après la
rencontrer l'autre qui s'est dit mon
père et qui lui m'a reconnu alors votre
père vous l'avez revu un jour ouais
vous lui avez dit écoute assume ta merde
et vous a répondu je t'emmerde pauvre
con et là j'ai tiré le rideau et j'ai
dit terminé parce qu'en fait si j'ai
pris rendez-vous avec lui c'était aussi
parce que mon fils a des problèmes et
que j'étais incapable de transmettre de
l'amour à mon fils tel qu'un père dans
transmettre à son fils et je tombe
l'avait pas appris bien sûr et c'est là
où je me suis dit le plus important en
fait c'est les enfants et les parents
s'ils sont pas bien et ben basta on les
balance quoi tant pis quelle histoire
nous on savait pas quand on vous voyait
comme ça ça vous faire du bien ce
bouquin vous verrez et puis de toute
façon
il faut s'occuper aimer vos enfants et
puis si vos parents sont pas bien c'est
pas très grave franchement balancer les
quoi
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu